[Music]
as the villain kids would say we got all
the ways to be wicked as hardcore fans
of descendants 1 & 2 we have dedicated
ourselves to the study of all things
wicked we had some fun and compiled a
list of all our favorite ways mal and
her crew are totally wicked if you're
new here be sure to subscribe to the
things channel for up to date videos and
if you like this one go ahead and click
the thumbs up button now back to all the
best ways to be wicked slow motion
dancing it's hard not to dance and cheer
to the opening number in descendants -
you know there's so many ways to be
wicked song it starts with the villain
kids gathered around a smoky cauldron
full of apples mouth opens her spell
books and casts a spell saying wicked
ways beneath the skin but all who taste
it now join in queue the evil villain
laughter we seriously love this opening
song that our favorite part has got to
be the slow-motion dancing we think
that's one excellent way to be wicked
watching Eevee slowly flip that blue
hair around and makes us wish we could
do everything in slow motion wear lots
of leather chorus on the costume
designer for descendants - ready -
unique look that sets the villain kids
apart from the other students at Arden
prep she caused the look wicked Couture
it involves chunky metal chains Deep
Purple's blues reds and golds and of
course lots and lots of leather if there
were any Cal's on the Isle before the
villain kids were born there's a good
chance there aren't any now they're
wicked awesome style really makes them
stand out and we can't forget umas look
the director Kenny Ortega said he wanted
it to look like she was dragged along
the bottom of the ocean
mission accomplished be chillin like a
villain so Evie basically lays out exact
instructions on how to be wicked in her
song tone like a villain that's the song
where evj and Carlos are trying to teach
Ben how to fit in on the Isle with the
other villains in order to be a villain
the gang stings that you need to drag
your feet and nod your head you need to
lean back and slip through the cracks
they say you need to not care and not
stare they also say you need to watch
your back move around slide real smooth
and don't make a sound
whoo it's a lot of work to be wicked be
a wicked good friends
thing about the villain kids is that
they are really good friends to each
other they are the only ones in auradon
who get what it's like to be from the
Isle and they have to stick together we
were over the magical moon when Evie
fought for dizzy to be able to leave the
isle to come to our dime one thing about
these wicked kids is that they've got
each other's backs friendship is the
thing that gets them through it all that
couldn't be more evident than at the end
when they dancin team together at the
cotillion when they sing it starts with
you and me cast spells in the beginning
of the sentence to mal was having a
pretty hard time fitting into her new
life everything feels different for her
she is trying so hard to forget her evil
roots that she almost loses herself
completely during that time she clings
to her spell book to help her keep up
with the good girl act she cast a spell
to speed-read make Ben a big fancy meal
at their picnic and ride her scooter on
the water when na loses her spell book
on the Isle
uma takes advantage and casts a love
spell on Ben it seems casting spells is
the ultimate act of wickedness for the
villain kids throw an awesome party can
we just talk about the awesome cotillion
for a second it had everything drawn
gorgeous ball gowns dancing and flipping
in the water and an epic battle between
mal as a dragon and uma as an octopus
one thing's for sure these wicked kids
know how to party now became a bad lady
of the court in style fans loved it and
we don't blame them we don't know how
they're going to top that awesome ending
with descendants three boomba will
probably crash the party again we hope
there is more of mal as a dragon kidnap
the boyfriend of your nemesis while now
Evie and Carlos and Jay are now living
in Oregon there are still villain kids
living on the Isle
uma and her crew are showing all the
ways to be wicked and looking good while
doing it
so what we've learned from Emma on how
to be wicked is to make your crew shout
your name repeatedly dance on tables and
kidnapped your enemy's boyfriend until
you get when he wants we don't advise
actually doing the last one now
outsmarted uma and cop different getting
fairy godmothers wand but uma got her
revenge when she cast that love spell
then unas really got this evil thing
down epic sword battles every great
fairy tales got one no we're not talking
about a sleeping damsel we're talking
about an epic sword battle from Peter
Pan to Mulan
so our battles are the ultimate climax
to any tale of magic and mayhem
descendants to is no different so did
they pull all the villain kids aside in
school and teach them how to sword fight
we know J is on the fencing team but how
does now know how to wield a sword
regardless they all look wicked cool
fighting on a pirate ship and it's nice
that a girl rescued a boy for once
Ben's a pretty good looking damsel right
break the rules you can't really say
you're wicked unless you've broken a few
rules
now breaks the rules when she keeps
using her spell book instead of putting
it in the museum Jay finds a clever way
around the rules when he makes Lani the
captain of the fencing team and we're
pretty sure they were not allowed to
make that dog talk rule breaking is part
of the villains squad wicked ways but
they appear to have respect for rules in
a lot of ways Eevee encourages Mau to
turn her spell book in and Jay works
around the fencing rules rather than
just outright breaking them could the
villain kids be getting soft take charge
of your own destiny one thing we love
about the characters in descendants two
is their rebellion against how they were
raised in the first movie Mau stands up
to her mom and decides she is going to
be good rather than follow in her mom's
evil footsteps the villain kids have
shown us that sometimes it's good to
choose for yourself the kind of person
you want to be they've shown us that
it's possible to take charge of your own
destiny and make things happen for
yourself
that's wickedly good what is your
favorite way to be wicked tell us in the
comments and those are all the ways to
be wicked in descendants - thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]